Is "Shazam! Fury of the Gods" a
"fun-filled" follow-up or just
a "muddy mess"? Early reviews are in
– here's what DC fans should expect.
The soon-to-be-retooled DC Universe is
attracting a fair amount of attention these days,
with fans wondering what direction James Gunn
and Peter Safran will take the struggling brand.
Would they want to compete directly with the MCU
and offer lighthearted fare for the whole family,
or would they double down on the dark and
gritty as it had done previously? Or perhaps,
would they finally figure out
how to successfully mix both?
As such, all eyes are on the upcoming "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods" movie, which is a direct
sequel to "Shazam!" While the film, alongside "The
Flash," was created before the decision to rework
the DCU, Safran is the producer and the film could
be a sign of what's in store for DC's future.
The original 2019 movie was praised for
its tone and for its general sense of fun,
and some wondered if the sequel would be able to
capture this lightning in a bottle once again. Now
that some early reactions are in for "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods," it looks like DC may have a
rare hit on their hands, which certainly
is a promising sign for what is to come.
Critics and others who have
been given the privilege of
seeing "Shazam! Fury of the Gods"
early have already started to heap
praise on the movie via Twitter.
John Nguyen of Nerd Reactor posted,
"'Shazam: Fury of the Gods' is a fun-filled
adventure that's a solid follow-up to the
first film. There is plenty of humor, action,
and heart, and it's always a treat to see the
family together again. I wish the movie was
longer since there are a lot of characters."
Cinema Blend's Eric Eisenberg also felt
the same way and wrote that "Fury of the
Gods" is a super fun and worthy sequel to
the original film. He added that although
the "Shazam!" sequel isn't a movie that
will forever change comic book movies,
it is still a great film filled with energy
and exceptionally likable characters.
Shahbaz from The Movie Podcast could barely
contain his feelings about the movie,
claiming that it is the most fun he's
have ever had at the movie theater,
and specifically praised the
performances of Helen Mirren,
Lucy Liu, and Rachel Zegler as well as
the efforts of director David F. Sandberg.
"The daughters of Atlas are coming to hunt us."
Jamie Broadnax of Black Girl Nerds
was another big fan, posting,
"Shazam continues to lean into his silliness
and immaturity in this sequel which tells us
this franchise will remain to keep these
films funny, light and slapstick-ish. The
sequel comes with more action, compelling
villains and a complicated antihero."
Brandon Davis of ComicBook.com was
also pleased with the movie, writing,
"It's a really good sequel. The theme of found
family delivers great emotional beats. Sandberg
sprinkles some horror elements while
maintaining the childish joy & charm
of the Shazamily. Nothing brand new but
highly entertaining! Really enjoyed [it]."
Variety's Courtney Howard said
that the sequel packs a punch,
adding that it delivers on all fronts.
MTV's Tyrell Charles was a little more
critical in his review and said that
even though "Shazam 2" is entertaining,
it is very much a standard-issue superhero film
with a third act that drags on a little bit.
Digital Spy's Gabriella Geisinger probably had
the spiciest opinion so far by saying that "Fury
of the Gods" only has a few bright spots and
that the third act is a muddy mess. However,
most early reviewers have thoroughly
enjoyed "Shazam 2" so it will be
interesting to see how general audiences
react to this latest offering from DC.